This video is proudly sponsored by North
Vpn.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
storytellers and use the Promo code
storytellers to get 75% off their three
year plan and she will also receive a
month for free,
right?
Politics is no longer just theater.
It's show business.
So let's put on the best show in town.
One of the most defining aspects of
house of cards is it's breaking of the
fourth wall inspired by Shakespeare's
King Richard,
the third.
Now he's the wind out of our discontent
made glorious summer.
This method of directly addressing the
audience is very effective in pulling
the audience closer towards the inner
thoughts and motivations of the main
character.
For those of us climbing
top of the food chain,
there can be no mercy.
There is but one hunt or be hunted
and house of cards.
This method is used to call Faye the
dual polarity between frank underwood's
inner thoughts and his personality and
his outwards behavior.
The image he constructs of himself.
We have to hold this sticky fingers and
wipe the filthy mouth.
Teach them right from wrong.
Tell them what to sync and how to see
you and what do we want.
This is central to what makes the show
so successful as a hyper reps inflation
or free or America politics as our
colleagues at waste cracker,
if bonded hours to officials in house of
cards often focus on theater,
aesthetics and art because this points
to the fundamental concepts that
appearance drives politics.
Politics is performance.
It is no coincidence that David fincher
is the executive producer and director
of the first two episodes of the show.
His camera movements are always smooth,
precise,
and in his own words,
moving perfectly.
A screen prison points out the color
Palette of the show is dark,
representing the underworld that the
underwoods move in and to cold blue and
warm yellow color contrasts represents
the pool between human warmness and
Colton ambition.
The composition is precise and set
designers thorough the way fincher
carefully constructed images to look
perfectly stands parallel to the way
frank and Claire Underwood Catholic
constructor own images,
images,
of course,
that height a darker reality.
That's right.
We don't submit the terror.
We make the terror.
Politics as theater is a criticism of
many contemporary scholars on bill life,
American politics just as to underwoods
image s carefully crafted and managed
from Cuba.
Tucsdon speeches,
live free or die,
live free or die
two well,
it's
kind of hairstyle or dress,
claire,
where's the same is true for real life.
American politicians,
so called establishment politicians on
both sides of the aisle tend to adopt
few points that resonate with the
biggest part of that base.
You were against same sex marriage.
Now your Ford,
you defended President Obama's
immigration policies.
Now you're saying they're too harsh.
He supported his trade deal dozens of
times.
You can call it the gold standard now
suddenly last week you're against it.
When you say anything to get elected,
they carefully avoid any controversy and
use catch phrases and slogans instead of
discussing nuance issues,
honestly and intellectually,
but I've tried to figure out how we get
them to have pokemon go to the polls
and we are going to make our country
great again.
The appeal of house of cards lies in its
confirmation or for what we already
suspect that it's behind the Catholic
cross.
The facade or decent politics.
There is dishonesty,
scheming,
blackmill,
rootless power,
hunger,
and maybe even criminality,
and this is the reason the audience
roots,
especially in the early seasons for it's
immoral,
may character,
frank underwood's,
he participates in a theater of
politics.
Birth only lets the viewers into the
real truth.
The fewer appreciates frank on the
woods.
Authenticity in those moments of
audience address,
even though it's authentic,
self is deeply immoral.
The road to power is paved with them
and casualties,
never,
right?
Correct.
Because we disliked the hypocrisy off
this political theater so much.
We love how frank uses it against
itself.
It does becomes clear that people are
hef and moral honesty.
Then moral dishonesty,
we simply detests hypocrisy or fake
morality more than authentic wickedness.
It is here to us.
We can make a comparison to real life.
American politics,
frank and Claire on the woods career
politician power couple dynamic has
often been compared to that of the
Clintons.
Just as to underwoods.
The Clintons represent carefully
constructed images and teared up
politics where the standpoints,
they take change according to what is
most popular with the base and as the
audience of house of cards like seeing
the Ari suspected power,
hunger and corruption behind the facade
of theater and the show,
it became increasingly clear the
citizens of the United States didn't
trust the establishment.
Politicians like the Clintons anymore
during the 2016 election and chose
something else.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
Complicated business
raccoon praise that trump receives from
his fence is that at least he tells it
like it is.
It says it like it is,
speaks to the truth.
It doesn't mean if what he says is mean
immoral or even to whether it's the
truth or not.
I think he tells you the way he feels.
What matters is that he sees what he
thinks filtering or changing his words
to protect this image.
I see the political rhetoric.
Most of the politicians talk and let's
say pastel colors.
They talk for two hours and you go away
saying,
what did they say?
If substance?
Probably nothing,
but they haven't offended anybody and
tried to make everybody to that friend.
Well,
if they're passed out,
uh,
Donald Trump is vivid colors because he
says things away.
They are
some fall so far outside of the
political theater that's Clinton
represents and to United States.
Citizens starts at tie off that he
became electable.
It's just awfully good that someone with
the temperament of Donald Trump is not
in charge of the law in our country
because you'd be in jail.
Since people will choose and moral
authenticity of both moral,
a dishonesty,
are we always choosing between liars and
crooks,
corrupt politicians and mean idiots?
Is there a place in Washington for
authentic,
idealistic,
honest politicians?
Welcome to the death of the age of
reason?
There is no right or wrong.
Not Anymore.
There's only being in
and then being out.
Can we move beyond tita politics and
into real intellectual debate where we
argue for our fuse,
both accept each other's differences?
Can we move to genuine politics within
the chaos off the 2016 election?
Hope for this appeared in a curious
form.
Various intellectuals or differing
opinion are holding civilize debates
where the RQ genuine authentic beliefs
without constructing or protecting the
images while also still respecting the
other.
Yes,
although they are gaining in popularity,
the question remains if such politics is
possible on a nationwide level.
Since authenticity also breeds
polarization,
can authentic politics captured the
majority of the masters or are the worst
sites or frank on the woods the best we
can do.
All right.
Thank you for watching everyone.
I know this video might be pretty
polarizing,
but I hope the common skin stay civil.
This video is sponsored by North vpm.
Using the Promo code storytellers as
North [inaudible] dot com slash story
tellers,
we will give you 75% of a three year
note vpn plan and it will also give you
a month for free.
Uh,
in the past I've had a couple scares
around my internet security.
For example,
with my paypal being hex,
which forced me to having to cancel my
credit cards.
Now,
using a vpn or virtual private network
allows you to hide and protect your
privacy and data on the Internet both
easily and safely.
I use snore,
tpn myself and it is incredibly simple
to use,
but don't let that fool you because
behind the simpleness not vpn uses
military grade encryption to connect you
to more than 61 different countries and
it's being able to connect to the
internet securely if I or different
places in the world is becoming
increasingly important with increased
government surveillance,
which has long been a hotly debated
subject in the us,
but now also the European Union passing
incredibly restrictive copyright loss,
death Vori.
Me and Tomas personally both for the
sake of this channel's existence and our
excess to memes having a vpn is becoming
essential,
so use our code storytellers on North
vpn.com/storytellers to get this
essential software for three years where
it's 75% off and a month for free.
It is easily installed and easily used
birth is offers a lot besides my
internet security and data protection.
I personally also just use it to access
Hong Kong's Netflix so I can watch the
same shows as my lung,
this and his girlfriend.
If you want to have access to additional
essays that has been blocked by Youtube
and receive some exclusive story teller
stickers,
you can support some patron.
It helps us keep the channel going and
thank you for watching.
We will see you next time.